we're coming up on the 25th anniversary
of you being on friends you remember
that I did is it that long Wow yes for
Frehley
yeah another 2015 look at rollerblading
now the Hadrosaurus have been unearthed
in two main locations what do you
remember about working on that job
well I remember quite a bit there's our
friends it was yeah there was six of
them yeah you know it's the one
experience I could say felt a little
similar where I kind of joined this
group you know I used joined within
quotes you know it's like I get to act
in scenes with some iconic characters
and actors in the Avengers and it felt a
little bit like that where I you know I
came on to friends and about season 9 it
was a mass so yeah well it was certainly
massive for me I got there I got bottled
breast milk I had never been in see a
part of anything that had that kind of
you know viewership and so everybody was
very nice but I never quite could get
over the fact that I was sitting in
Central Park and I just didn't want to
get in the way and knew no one was
tuning in for Mike Hanigan so I you know
I just I was like oh wow I'm just gonna
sit back and kind of observe and enjoy
this ride Mike Hanigan yeah I love that
Mike and again yeah it was he your
favorite friend my favorite friend I'm
glad you brought it back up tan again on
everybody's lips everybody yeah well
they talked about friends you can't you
can't say friends without ham yeah you
can't spell friends without Hanigan I'm
not even gonna try and figure that out
[Music]
[Applause]